نعم ، تلك الخطوط التي تراها
هناك في السماء ، لا أعرف كيف يمكننا أن
نرى بالضبط الآن يمكنك رؤية المزيد من
صواريخ المدفعية تطلق على ما يبدو
من الأراضي الروسية باتجاه
المنطقة التي أود أن أقولها حول
سمع ، أعلم أنه يمكنك سماع  لن أتحدث الآن
[الموسيقى
] لثانية واحدة
[موسيقى] ،
لذا فهذه دفعة أخرى لما
نعتقد أنه قاذفات صواريخ مدفعية متعددة
كانت
تنطلق هنا ، قل الضربة الثانية أو الثالثة
التي رأيناها هنا أنا فقط  أريد أن
أشرح سريعًا حقًا أين أنا
جون بالفعل لأنني عند آخر نقطة تفتيش
قبل خط المواجهة بالقرب من هاركو ، فأنا على
الجانب الروسي أنا جنوب مدينة بيلغورود
وما تراه
خلفي هناك هو  نوع من آخر
نقطة تفتيش وفي هذا الاتجاه
هناك حيث أه حيث سيكون هاركيف
حيث كان لدينا سام كايلي من قبل ، فما
رأيناه هنا خلال
الدقيقتين الماضيتين خلال الـ
45 دقيقة الماضية حقًا منذ أن كنا هنا
م  أو صاروخًا يتم إطلاقه
الآن إذا نظرنا إلى السماء يمكننا رؤيته
هناك إذا كان بإمكاني أن أطلب منك التوقف لثانية واحدة
هنا فريد أعتقد أننا نرى بعض
المعدات خلفك تتدحرج بشكل عام ،
انظر إلى هذا إذا كان بإمكانك ذلك
جون نعم ،
نعم ، هناك عمود من
دبابات القتال الرئيسية التي ستأتي إلى هنا ، أود أن
أقول إنها نوع من طراز T-72
يمكنك أن تقول إنها تمريرات متدحرجة ولكن
عليك التحدث بصوت عالٍ جدًا لأنها من
الواضح أنها  بصوت عالٍ للغاية
وهم يتدحرجون هنا ، فهم يتخطون
موقعنا الآن وما يمكنك رؤيته
هنا هو أن مساراتهم
قذرة جدًا لذا لا بد أنهم قد تم حفرهم في
بعض الحقول والآن نوعًا ما يغيرون
مواقعهم
بعدنا الآن وهذا هو حقًا
شيء يمكننا الاقتراب منه ، يمكنك أن ترى
أن مساراتهم مغطاة حقًا
بالطين ، لذا يجب أن يكونوا قد تم حفرهم
في نوع من المواقع الميدانية حيث
إنهم يتقدمون إلينا الآن و  الآن إذا
تحركنا يمكنك أن ترى أن
هؤلاء  تتقدم مركبات se أيضًا
John الآن إلى الأمام ،
ومن الواضح أن هذه المركبات تتحرك الآن للأمام
نحو أراضي أوكرانيا ، لقد
أتوا من مكان ما على الجانب الذي قاموا
به للتو في هذا المنعطف وهذا هو
بالضبط الطريق المؤدي إلى أوكرانيا ، لذلك هذا
بالتأكيد بالنسبة لنا  يبدو كما لو أن
ما نراه الآن هنا هو أن
أجزاء من الجيش الروسي
تتحرك أكثر في أوكرانيا تنقل
أجهزتها إلى أوكرانيا